for a hundred and fifty years scientists
have been puzzled by the fate of the
Neanderthals why such as strong well
adapt his species disappeared one of the
world's leading anthropologists Ian
Tattersall believes we're to blame
our ancestors must force the
Neanderthals into extinction
Homo sapiens modern humans evolved in
Africa we didn't set first on European
soil until about 40,000 years ago
but once we did was there any matter of
time before we ran into the inhabitants
of this continent the Neanderthals
modern humans would clearly have seen
something very similar to themselves in
these creatures that they encountered in
this new world that they were entering
well ecology but I don't think that they
were to have identified with each other
particularly closely and I think they
would have perceived themselves as being
in competition water
Akagi
with modern humans simply slaughter the
Neanderthals
or was the interaction more subtle
instead of killing them perhaps be our
competed tinny and attles
we may have been better at finding
different source of food
whatever happened modern humans
our ancestors one out today is obvious
who dominates the planet Neanderthals
are no more
but anthropologist John Hawkes believes
his version of the story is way too
simple
he thinks that modern humans were not
really so different from the
Neanderthals when they met our ancestors
would have been curious not hostile
it would be insane to go out and pick a
fight you're not a military organization
going in you know looking to conquer
you're a small group yourself hey Bianca
you sort of have to you know find a way
to live with the locals and as you do
that you learn from them to some extent
and the locals learn from you
I feel like the defense attorney for the
Neanderthals sometimes I'm trying to see
the ways that they overlap with us and
trying to add complexity to this story
because any story that involves things
happening over a continent over
thousands of years it's got to be
complicated how far might the overlap
have gone instead of making war perhaps
they made love
the two species exchange genes it's an
intriguing idea but hard to prove the
fossils are inconclusive the answers by
an DNA an international team of
geneticists is trying to crack the
Neanderthal code it's a hugely ambitious
project that could reveal who the
Neanderthals really were and whether
their genes live on inside of us